you'll be happy to know that the museum
has made another contribution that Gregg
neglected to mention through painstaking
effort they've transferred my only film
that I mentioned looking for love from
regular film to flammable nitrate stock
one of the next presenters is mr. Yul
Brynner and tonight is quite an event
for you because this is the first time
in two years
he's worked with his shoes on and with
him one of Hollywood's most exciting
actresses ladies and gentlemen Yul
Brynner and Natalie Wood
Yesi Cynthia vegan wah tous rainy so SWA
what you'll is saying is that it's very
very lovely to see you here tonight at 8
vs natalka G Hollywood yet vecher doc
Evo Mira
Natalie's saying to us that that this
Academy Awards is an international event
the sarvesh the Tring deaf academia del
passive karma film and a aware doneski
sheep etc etc etc you'll just said that
this is the 23rd year then award is
being presented to the outstanding
foreign language film I didn't know that
you spoke shitty you'll I was gypsy
well when it comes to foreign films we
can be glad that there is no language
barrier and by way of introduction this
year's nominees for the outstanding
foreign film are from France get out
your handkerchiefs from the German
Federal Republic the glass cell
from Hungary Hungarians from Italy Viva
Italia
when the USSR white bin black ear and
the winner is France
forget out your handkerchiefs
excuse me I am without voice I am just
able I'm only able to say one thing is
thank you thank you for the Academy and
thank you for all the American Friends
of our film our picture excuse me
thank you very much thank you for your
honor
we are very deeply touched and of course
there is nothing to cry but let me get
out by handkerchief I must say we came
here to win we extend expected more or
less who could be good lost and we won
thanks to you to your kindness and to
your taste - thank you FC merci beaucoup
you